I don't want to get you in trouble I
know the first season is h10 episodes
Whatever It Is Well I'll be sent to the
planet Purgatory if I say anything wrong
I'm just curious of the first season
which uh episode number uh are you most
excited for fans to see
there's eight episodes I would say
one two eight
you cannot you cannot it's like
separating a family say which child's
your favorite child right you just say
well yeah but that one's good but then
that one's got there and then no I got
it yeah it's no it's a whole day so uh
one of the things Dave wrote Dave filoni
wrote all the episodes what surprised
you about his writing and uh the scripts
of the first season that you weren't
expecting
I think the vision and complexity and
the newness that's that's being given to
the new entities the new uh uh scale
there's a there's a certain scale to
Ahsoka I think it's a everybody's saying
this has sprinkled with a bit of pixie
dust on this one
um I remember walking on sets and going
like who designed this and then walking
up to the set at Southern who
constructed this and everybody brought
and they're bringing their a game and
they're just like uh the costumes are
Works about so in the storylines
themselves it second guesses it's this
it's that it's that oh right that's
going to lead to no it's not it's
leading to this it's either and there's
a lot of cliffhanging surprises and
Journeys and unexpected event and he
just kept it going it kept it coming so
it was just a delight to go to work
exhausting but a delight we saw in the
footage that you get involved in the
action and obviously and it looks so so
good I'm just curious what can you tease
about the uh the spectacle the action
that you were involved in
well the way the amazing stunt team that
we work with headed by Ming the
incredible fight coordinator is such
that we arrive and we're already getting
the tip of the iceberg the cream how
much have they already dismissed and
worked out for camera so we stepping in
and that's they're working the fights
out with our characters in mind and that
and then you get on set and you get in
real life there's they're
character-driven fights and I think it's
not just here's a lightsaber fight it's
that character the stakes are up you
don't know who's going to come out of it
or how they're going to come out of it
you may think you do but when you're in
it the dynamic the energy involved they
literally keep you on the edge of your
seat one of the things about thrawn is
that he's the smartest one in the room
I'm gonna take a boat
[Laughter]
right I got it I was just going to say I
wanted I was curious about your
relationship with him if advertis Ariel
or friendly or what can you tease
yes
the last thing for you I love learning
about the behind the scenes the making
of a show what surprised you about
making a Star Wars show uh that you
didn't expect
as I was just alluding uh Shauna who's
the head of the Wardrobe department for
foreign
next thing I know Dave said I love it
it's Incorporated and there's five
costumes and they're all hand stitched
and the work and the detail and the that
the enthusiasm gone in the collaborative
nature of all this as well is is what's
breathtaking
who designed this and then who
constructed that that attention they did
everybody's bringing
I tell you what it is Dave filoni and
John Favreau have this unique ability to
facilitate everybody to bring their best
of themselves to work I'm not expecting
Geniuses are just the best of you and to
have that why do you get up in the
morning to go to work with the hope that
you're able to bring the best of you to
work
and that's what they have and it's it
comes down as a humility of greatness
from them and that was the most
I don't know I mean so you know
empowering and wonderful and humility
and humble it makes it easy to come on a
red carpet and talk about a show when
you're that passionate about it of
course because there's a genuine love
there and you feel that now and
resonated as a tsunami of love from the
fans that's from the cast and crew as
well just want to give it to the
audience who deserve it and give them
everything and they facilitate just
bring your best to work yeah I gotta
stop there I'm just gonna say man I am
really looking forward to this series I
wish you nothing but the best thank you
so much